foreign
we got Leslie in Los Angeles California
what's up with you Leslie
hi thank you for taking my call I was
wondering is it wise to spend overspend
or spend without any limits on kids
activities since we're investing in them
um I'm also asking because we kind of
overspent on a house but other than that
we are very wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute well I think you're kind
of answering your own question because
you said the word overspend hold on I I
gotta I gotta dig in
this is my favorite Leslie I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get myself in trouble is that
okay come on John
sure when you say you're investing in
your kids what does that mean
um I mean I I just wanna you know my
parents they invested in us like I had
opportunities to try everything so now
the career I have is exactly what I want
to do and I I have a great job well what
if I told you wait can I stop you what
if I told you I had the opportunities to
do almost nothing when I was a kid and
I'm in a job that I love and I love my
job
does that hit you any type of way when
you look at your kids
if you look at your kids as an Roi
proposition financially
you're going to get into a mess
okay
you're gonna get you a message okay so
it gives people license to I have to
send them to every sporting event all
these crazy
insane travel sport nonsense
um all of the uh
not only do we have to do uh music
lessons we have to do all the music
lessons and by the way my kids are in
music lessons and my kids do one thing
each right so when it comes to brain
development yeah I guess you can call
that an investment when it comes to
Social Development having just having
fun yes all those things are good but if
you're thinking I'm gonna overspend
right now I am going to
make my house more anxious more chaotic
so that they can maybe one day get their
dreams that's that that math doesn't
work that's good how much are you
spending how much are you spending and
overspending
uh okay so we we spent easily up two
thousand dollars between two kids okay
and I have three kids um two older kids
and then the youngest one goes to
daycare but I mean that expense you have
to spend it sure but the activities for
the older kids of like thousand over a
thousand a month how much debt do you
have
um so we don't have any debt except for
the the house
um so we have
um uh we're spending we're paying 3 500
a month on our house
um but we also took have to take out a
second loan um to buy the house because
we didn't have enough to put down
um sorry you had to you just had to huh
no we were finally ready to buy a house
and that's when everything went crazy I
know but you know it was not ready for a
house purchase was math
math wasn't right y'all were ready but
math was what's what's your monthly take
home what's your take home because I
want to see what percentage
this mortgages we make about 20 000 from
both of us per month
yes okay so your mortgage is fine
um no no but we have more we have that
second mortgage how much is that for 10
years that's for 10 years and it's 2600
and we owe we borrowed about a hundred
thousand dollars from a family member
and that's where we were paying them
twenty five hundred dollars a month for
the next seven years so you're paying
years you're paying 6 100 a month for
the home
the 2500 to your friends
is that right yeah two yeah family
member yeah so 3 500 for the actual
mortgage twenty six hundred dollars for
them for 10 years for the second
mortgage and twenty five hundred dollars
for seven years to a family member
Leslie you I can hear that you know that
this is insane you're paying 8 600 a
month to tackle all of the cares of this
mortgage
almost half of your take-home pay
yeah and then we're spending it okay
okay okay okay and you're 20 grand does
that take home or is that is that gross
that's take home okay all right all
right the good news is you've got a
great
yearly income and you've got a great
monthly income that's the good news the
bad news is you're not being a good
manager of this money
um and I I hate the what this mortgage
is doing to you the 20 pipe hundred that
you're paying to your friends when is
that when does that end What's the total
amount and when is that over
um I I think it's good that we have six
more years let's um about six more years
left how can you pay it off we need to
get that paid off sooner
because you said you had no debt but
this is debt so if you said you're
paying 2500 for six years
how can we get that done faster the only
debt worse than owing a friend six
figures is IRS debt yeah so destructive
to the soul of a relationship
you owe them fifteen thousand dollars
and you make twenty thousand dollars a
month how quickly can you get them that
money
yeah
15 grand or you owe him a hundred grand
no it was about a hundred thousand yeah
I don't know the exact number yeah so it
it kind of uh when we did the
calculations it was about twenty five
hundred dollars for uh seven years
girl
dude girl here here's where this ends
this is ins and Ash it ends in a huge
mess no you like I was gonna say you
can't afford to send your kids to that
kind of expense yeah you can't
absolutely not you got to clean up this
this dollar broke you are wealthy broke
people what is this house worth
um so we bought it for one 1.35
um I think it's about 1.5
I
but you have no equity in it do you
uh we put down yeah probably
um because you had to borrow from three
different sources just to get in the
front door
yeah you guys we were supposed to buy
like a million dollar home we had 10 for
that but it just went crazy and we would
buy like nothing for a million no it
didn't go crazy you went crazy thank you
you went crazy it didn't it is just its
own thing you all went
b-a-n-a-n-a-s here's the problem here's
a problem Leslie and and and I I gotta
get I gotta get in my my jade stance
here for a minute because
you've got it you've got to you've got
to start with the man in the mirror you
gotta look at this and go I and my
husband did every part of this the
market didn't just happen something
didn't just up and happen to you you
went along for the ride and you signed
up for it and you were like hey we'll do
this hey you called in the show and said
I'm overspending which means you know
that you're doing it but you're still
trying to find this external thing to
blame for or say that it's okay you're
if you don't start changing your habits
and changing them quick you're gonna be
up you're already up a creek without a
paddle you guys Gotta Get This Money
paid off you make two money too much
money to be this broke if a bank won't
loan you money
if they won't do it then something's up
sums up because a bank will give money
they will lend money they will give
money to a pet
dope they'll issue a loan for a dead
person the bank if the bank won't do it
you ain't got no business getting it